hey guys this is the study of january
and the knees is coming back at you from
down under where it is very very hot
please start down your funders winter
memory in the comment section so i can
try and live vicariously through anyway
let's get on with the knees also I'm
just you probably remove that
temperatures in Sydney might be rising
but unfortunately Capcom chef are
falling as resident evil 7 sold less
copies in previous games Capcom had
previously announced that resident evil
7 was off to a solid start having
shipped 2.5 million copies to retailers
following the game's launch on January
24 since the announcement of the 2.5
million figure Capcom shares have taken
a tumble on the tokyo stock exchange as
you can see in this not so awesome
looking graph shares are now down more
than three percent and it's suspected
this could be due to investors being
worried that resident evil 7 first week
sales failed to surpass that of resident
evil 5 already 6 which both shipped
around four million in their respective
launch weeks Capcom has forecast rosy
seven to sell 4 million copies before
the end of its financial year which ends
on March 31 keeping with the theme of
apocalyptic weather let's talk fallout
focus Oakheart CEO of fallout new vegas
developer obsidian entertainment told
IGN that the company was working on to
fallout three projects before the game's
launch in 2008 while operating as black
our studios are cut explained that one
of these projects eventually became the
RPG dungeon crawler icewind dale he said
we were moving forward but we were
really learning and it was went into
play publisher fallout at the time
started to run into financial trouble
and that was where I swindell came from
the fallout 3 team became the icewind
dale team another of these projects with
the more widely reported game codenamed
vans urine in other flat news Bethesda
has announced that the ps4 and PC
versions of flirt for are receiving free
updates next week the pc version will
receive a high resolution texture pack
as a love letter to fans but you'll need
an additional fifty eight gigabytes of
space to download it the ps4 update will
add support for the s4 pro which
includes features such as native 1440p
resolution enhance draw distance and
enhanced cadre effect says there has not
announced any release dates for these
updates as yet
finally the deus ex series may have been
put on hiatus but developer idols seem
to have something else up their sleeve
Eurogamer has reported that publisher
Square Enix opted to Hulk work on deus
ex games in part due to underwhelming
sales of the most recent installment
mankind divided Eurogamer also claims
that the publishers shift into the
development of Marvel games was also a
factor the first in this series will be
a new avengers project from Deus Ex to
do idols Montreal kotaku have reported
from what we hear Square Enix doesn't
plan to greenlight another day sex game
at idle Montreal for quite some time
unless mankind divided suddenly becomes
more profitable it's not all doom and
gloom though as it appears a guardians
of the galaxy game is in the works at I
dot that's according to Eurogamer
sources and kotaku reportedly the game
is in the early stages of production if
a guardians of the galaxy game sounds
awfully familiar that's because telltale
also has one in the works which are
scheduled to arrive at this year inside
news Messiah Nakamura the founder of
historic Japanese games publisher Namco
passed away on January 22 at the age of
91 Namco confirmed the news today
Nakamura spent his early life founding
Nakamura manufacturing a company that
made amusement rides for children the
business was later abbreviated to namco
and moved on to the video games market
where it created arcade games like
pac-man and ridge racer Nakamura has
left an indelible mark on this industry
and our thoughts go out to his family
and friends that is all the bits and
pieces I've got for you today to head to
gain squat for a feature on horizon zero
dawn and I will catch you again tomorrow
you